I don't even want to turn that music
down you should just listen to the
soundtrack and call it a doom the best
part about this I know right so I'm Eric
that jean-luc as our thirds would say it
is a Thursday it's pretty red in here
we're gonna go to hell on switch because
that's a thing now
doom is on switch tomorrow we're playing
early on a like review copy yep and this
is it I didn't even ask you before we
streamed are we early on here or what
it's not like Midway great it's the
first time you go to hell yep our review
in progress is also up because we're
holding off to check multiplayer when it
comes out proper but Peter Brown's
review
oh is this right before that little
bought mini boss fight yeah the first
time you see the big dude yeah alright
and yeah well the frame rates already
dying
cool it's fine ya know well we'll talk
about it a little bit here more since
you have played it for a good couple
hours at least not more to just talk
about your opinions of your experience
with doom on switch yeah okay personal
opinion report
Jim last year was like my number one
game nine a year I think like number I
think it was like top three for me if
not number two maybe maybe even one
though yeah definitely up there for me
as well and the best I can say about
this is like it's serviceable okay here
sometimes the frame rates fine earlier
yeah kind appends on like the level I'm
like how much stuff is on the screen
right oh you could pick that up okay
look at you remembering and saving all
your stuff like that guy I still think
that like I don't know the other the
other thing to talk about which was like
part of the oh that's all right quad
damaged part of the thing that I was
excited about when I heard that doing
was coming this which was the fact that
you could you know bringing on the bus
so bring it on the bar and that could be
killing demons that while listening a
sweet sweet metal yeah but it turns out
that handheld experience is pretty poor
no yes I'm playing on the pro controller
right now and I think it's definitely if
you're gonna play it I think you'll find
controllers but you kind of with a game
like this you sort of realize the
sensitivity of those sticks are not that
great for like a fast-paced game that
requires like a little more precision
and so like that just feels really
really clumsy from the plane can help
and then on top of that kind of thinking
about just like being itself like when I
think of the best which games would
handheld you know it's something you can
kind of like slower paced you can pick
up and put down do requires so much of
your attention that it's like I would
not want to play this on the bus right
we're like I can be easily distracted
I haven't tried it myself I guess I
should've did that right before we
played what's amazing on the switch do I
disagree especially when you put it on a
TV like I played at home when I put on
at home it it looks so like Jackie you
like the ain't it there's there's no
anti-aliasing feels like it is terrible
and then on top of that there's like
this just as um blur to the whole thing
that is I think well let me also just
put this into perspective true right
like I think part of it is because you
played doom on PC with like really good
you know like settings and everything
like that whereas some people I think
yeah the best version nos nassos
carve said he you played doom on his PC
but with literally with 10 FPS so I'm
guessing you know there's probably
people that played doom enjoyed doom on
PC at like you know moderate to lower
and graphic settings and still enjoyed
the game with like kind of frenetic
fast-paced gameplay so I don't know I I
saw I didn't notice that it doesn't look
as good obviously but I went on Xbox one
for the first time I played it and then
I eventually did play a little bit on PC
and it was still I think the experience
is still very fun for me so I think just
having it on switch is pretty cool now
and I do think it is impressive vadik
camera on the switch like there there is
a little bit of a novelty that but it's
not an experience that I find myself
really enjoying like I think you know
you already played
yeah I think it's also to try to open up
to new users that you know might have
never played this as epic milk said he
you know he played through doom at 14:40
ultra and thinks this looks spa-like
okay
you know and he's glad that more people
get to experience it I also think yes
and you know editing on premiere it's a
tiny window and also this doesn't look
that bad
yeah I think it depends I the framerate
stuff kind of bothers me but watching
you play right now like I don't know I
guess it wouldn't bother me but it
depends right like there's like one of
my examples probably would be that okay
some people have to watch anime in HD I
can watch my room both no it's kind of a
lot some people need to watch anime in
HD I'll watch it at like 480 because
it's fine and doesn't bother me but
that's not everyone right so moving so
quick and I do think it's like see
naughty doctor says look so blurry when
you are trying to just like look at the
environment or even there's a part where
I was just watching like not a cutscene
but it's like a moment where you're
looking at like one of the characters
and it's really just hurt my eyes out
for a while playing it and I find that
to be a very
again this is a that's John Lewis
personal opinion of his his playthrough
and everyone has their opinion I think
so I know man still feel it still feels
good to see doom baby
at the end of the day like it is still
doom and there is something to be said
about but I don't know this just made me
want to play the PC version is I think
it looks fine and you know if you end up
getting this enjoying it like all - you
only have power - you're still playing
doom that's cool yeah man I love I
should go back and play do them again
just cuz like I don't know I even when I
beat the game I found a reason to go
back cuz I was like man I'm gonna get
like every mod and like mess around with
like you know like the other way of
using this gun no I didn't is that this
is the arcades in this - no it's in this
oh we should check that out later yeah
updates a day and all the DLC is that
the one where like I saw you playing I
think yesterday there has like a lot of
points kind of pop up on this yeah
that's cool it's nice they unlock all
the Arcade Mode just has all the levels
awesome start miles is making a fun joke
saying that I called it every game is a
6 or 7 on your site that's hilarious
considering how many 9
and we gave up yeah if anything I feel
like yeah we've been more on a higher
yeah
gave out 210 breath little wild
Mario Odyssey so I think you just are
selectively checking certain games or
something yeah some people are saying it
seems to be running good well we can see
if we can find a spot where like it kind
of gets a little hairy okay yeah I was
most part it runs okay like I feel like
it always runs just those couple
instances like that one time I was
watching play at one room with like next
up the jump out the jump pads I think
and like just all the minions like you
could see that the frame rate was
dipping into like the 10 of the 10 or 12
but yeah like he said I feel like it's
been pretty pretty ok so far that hot ok
yeah ok that's not an experience I want
in this game ok Miles said right I said
earlier every game besides Mario so what
about a breath of the wild mm-hmm
just gave you another example or persona
5 I don't I don't know why we gave call
duty a 9 yeah yeah oh that's right I
don't even know why I'm engaging now
three tens is here it's gonna be a tough
game of the Year discussion which is
coming up soon
nice yeah I was gonna say have you I
don't it doesn't seem like you've
upgraded the rock looks like the combat
the the shotgun you've upgraded though
because it's got that quick reload yeah
you want the DEP I like the the micro
missiles on the heavy assault was like
one of my go to it just like that
feathering of the missiles sound that's
so great and I'm guessing you don't have
the cows yet either right that's like
one of my favorite go okay the cows is
so good
I forget which version I had but I don't
know yeah I think they must have heads
his arms all of it then you just got
that music for music so then yeah I know
the music is still good audio flips
we're like the main channel cuts out and
you can only hear like
and then Peter had it crashed a couple
times we actually had a crash once right
before we started playing yeah again
guys that's just you know our opinions
of the game like don't like read about
it I mean you know like I said some
people you know visually will think this
is totally good and fine for them you
know whereas John Luke doesn't like you
know like I said he is used to another
like way of playing this game matter of
perspective about it I mean no I I never
try and be like PC
yeah you're not Ellen and elitist right
for me at least like having played it on
PC this feels like such a downgrade that
is hard for me to like want to play this
but I think you've never played doom you
were to play this version first hey
hello ah God with that your leg yeah yes
glory kills are always satisfying
I agree Chamorro tips and you want to do
them because again we're like health and
ammo and stuff let's go to a PC version
expecting PC quality of course I mean I
didn't expect peace equality but what I
was hoping for was that the downgrades
in quality visually would equal a
consistent frame rate mm-hmm and the
fact that it does drop to those tens I
find pretty disappointing and then the
while the textures are kind of muddy and
gross at times it's the it's really the
blurriness of it that actually gets to
me because I was giving me like
headaches gotcha
I mean like so like I and then the fact
that I think playing on handheld with a
joy cons kind of a bad like it didn't it
doesn't feel good for me which then
means okay well then the best way to
play is on a TV with a pro controller at
which point well I have the PC version
myself so why don't I just playing back
Katie drag Neil I would say if you're
debating between ps4 and switch and
you're gonna mostly play on TV I would
go with the ps4 version personally if
for some reason you feel like you're
gonna play it in handheld mode which for
the most part from what I understand
isn't as great of an experience then
switch it depends I think been also been
Janka who's a philanthropy in our
YouTube chat has also played on handheld
and was kind of like I don't want to
necessarily put words in the mouth but
that's the what I remember him saying
the other day
yeah so it's not like we're completely
bashing it and and whatnot but it's just
it's hard when you played one version of
the game and then you're coming to this
version you know what I mean like I
absolutely think it is a much better
experience with the send size disciple
it doesn't have less features it just
graphically yeah I mean the whole games
here yeah which is cool I'm carrying
something multiplayer holds up
I do multiplayer was kind of it man
that's the anyway so it's like I thought
like yeah I thought that the
single-player alone was like good enough
for me I played some multiplayer here
and there but like it was mainly
single-player for me I actually always
wanted to go back and do one of those
like perma death runs or whatever so
does that take away the wheel too or you
get the wheel that keeps the wheel but
you're playing on mouse and keyboard I
just needs the but it doesn't move how
much ammo you don't have to know how
much ammo you have you don't know how
much health you have however on the
harder difficulties that kind of doesn't
matter because you are either dying or
you're not dying is how I kind of see it
and the game does indicate whether the
low on health because it kind of gets
read around the edges of the screen yeah
so you have an indication of whether you
need health or not and I
I would keep so you can change the
crosshairs I would put just the simple
fog crosshairs
yes can I found it to be a really fun
experience I if anyone ever wants to
like replay doom I recommend start
saying something about so yeah that was
something Peter was kind of saying this
with you which is like a point in this
game's favor is there really is nothing
there's no game like this on the switch
so as far as like
do you have motion blur on okay
someone was saying that like if you
turned it off maybe that'll help with
the it doesn't know that it it doesn't
hope with the blurriness now because the
blurriness is not related to the motion
blur the blurriness is related to the
resolution of the game like I'm standing
still and we're not reviewing the game
right now Leandro B we're just sharing
our opinions of what he's played if you
want to review check out GameSpot review
by Peter Brown it's on the site and I
will stop doing comparisons to other
platforms once you guys also stop
talking about it cuz it's like yeah
obviously the reason why we're talking
about it cuz you guys are talking about
it so I will I will stop doing that now
though if that's what you guys want yeah
if you just want me to compare it on its
own I would say the frame rate is is
serviceable enough to be playable it's
fine but then there are a lot of times
where it does get quite significantly
that makes it very unplayable and I find
that disappointing but it doesn't happen
often enough that I think some people
will be okay and then like that and then
the blurriness is a huge issue for me
and then also I think the joy cons are
not serviceable controls to play it's
comfortable so yes so that's that
response that last response he said
basically about the joy Kahn's and hand
held from the from the few people I've
talked to our heard from it has not been
a great experience portable so for the
people saying that don't thought you
wouldn't dock this game it's portable
you can play it like you obviously
haven't played it yet so we're trying to
give you guys that information and
granted that's only a few people's
opinion on playing handheld but
generally if you have three or four
people kind of saying the same thing
it's most likely at least in some cases
not as good as it should be so just be
aware of that we're just trying to give
you guys information so those trying to
like think that we're overly bashing or
anything it's not because of that if you
got if you guys don't want to hear our
opinions or you guys aren't happy with
that stuff you don't have to watch you
don't have to be here like that's just
like the simple thing like I mean we can
shift focus we could just talk about how
cool Doom is yeah Doom is dooms pretty
[ __ ] cool glory kills metal music
killing demons do that all day they're
probably favorite game of 16 activate
that portal
yeah this game is I mean this game is
great I love all the collectables I love
the upgrades yeah you're gonna yeah just
make sure you're talking to that yes
sorry now you're good charlie
I kind of boosted up your mic too so we
go here the funny thing acrid red is
that the switch itself will output like
1080 60 so a weird thing like my capture
output it at 1080 but the game was but
that's this is the game runs that at 720
but also like even though they say it's
outputting at 720 like there's no way
that is 720 resolution di Ravello there
is motion control stuff we can mess
around with that a little bit so here's
a question in Zelda did you use motion
controls with a bow and arrow because I
turned that off personally okay I could
not I didn't know it was the the aiming
with the like yeah don't just do it in
door on door John Luke so he's now
playing on motion controls and not the
pro controllers okay this is the
joystick to submit
okay sure oh that's it
twister NL I implore you to install doom
again and play because it is a fun time
oh no they just haven't played it in a
while it's my guess and they just like
now that they've seen doom again they
just want to play it again lay for
jumper to ask him what's the frame wait
like on Twitch
it's like mostly 30 but then it dips
right it just depends on like the area
and how many enemies there are probably
most of the time mm-hmm
it's only when it really dips that it's
like we haven't had one of those moments
quite yet but if we get to one hopefully
you'll see what we're talking I know
we're ones like reliably happened the
problem is like replaying that level
it's the one that requires you climbing
up the tower it's a lot of platforming
and the platform you find in that game
but that part was just like a little too
much platforming for my taste and here a
guy on screen right that which is John
Luke that's me hi I don't talk a lot
enough hello I've boosted him I can
boost him some more hey everybody how's
it going we're playing doom there's that
Gatling gun yeah get it
so I'm curious how oh yeah just people
can tell here but like the crosshair on
the Gatling that you can light on us I
can see I can count the pixels hmm and
let's just it doesn't look good I mean I
can try to see what it looks like on
preview but they but the thing is
they're probably not watching full
scripts of things so like you wouldn't
really really carry towel so they're
also gonna be putting Wolfenstein yeah
game yeah I could see yeah I can see
that because there's like yeah so I
think I'm curious to see how Brendan
ginder we are playing on switch right
now and then the other one Skyrim and
that one I would assume actually would
probably be fine just scare rooms next
week right
17th well probably will probably stream
that as well let me double check the
Skyrim day for you guys we're pretty
sure it's the 17 so that the thing about
Skyrim is that I mean I don't know what
your version they're porting over but
the yeah the 17th you know that game
originally came out on the 360 and the
ps3 which the switch is very much
comparable I can Kiki maybe a little bit
better than so that is something that I
could easily be ported over to the
switch and I imagine wouldn't have
problems at least that's what I would
hope for right is that the so I have I
still have a pretty
Sopot dizzle so the only thing with
playing handheld John Luke as experience
is that just like that he doesn't feel
that the joy cons are as good as like
playing on a pro controller and so Oh at
least you got that though you got that
hot motion
yeah whip it and that that has been true
with a couple other people I've talked
to I it's my fault for not trying it
beforehand but it was busy at least
there's that that seems kind of fun and
novel no really got a couple minutes but
of all the things they get it done with
it
I don't know if you could really like
attached rumor circles in this game
though what I like
I mean if anything though I am glad that
there's going to be hopefully some new
new players experiencing doom and this
is an interesting kind of like what
first look at like an FPS switch right
like it hasn't really it is the first
one right that I can think oh you didn't
do it I think it's a very interesting
like test case I think it's feasible on
the go it's just not as it like for how
precise you want to potentially be in
this game you probably want to play on a
pro controller I will have to play some
after this I'm just gonna steal John
with bird and give it a go both in like
with pro controller and handheld okay
I'll try that in a little bit just I
mean I can't see the screen so
Oh minecraft is gonna be perfect on this
which that is a game you could totally
oh yeah oh you got the heat pulse thing
uh I never used that thing right
I use the other option there's another
option right what's the other pulse
rifle option I can't use it all the time
I never wanted to be that close you can
do it it's like the way I'm Amy I'm
because I [ __ ] like this are you just
you're just shaping into it oh look the
normal weapon switch
don't don't get quickly this is so good
for taeho
I mean when some of you guys get the
chance tomorrow I'll try it on joy Kahn
see how it is for you guys
yeah it's tried enough and he'll let's
see how it's for you guys also I would
try to show you guys what that would
like be like in handheld but there's not
really a way to capture video and audio
well it's like handheld so yeah exactly
so I'd have to grab a camera like
literally pointed at his you know it's
just kind of the text just kind of
blurry you know I mean there's there's a
lack of sharpness to some of the UI that
I find kind of strange yeah but I never
read this no I know you don't I just
saying I find it a little weird how
blurry this stuff is like shouldn't this
be sharper looking no it's not something
that I think really negatively affects
the game cuz you're right like notices
stuff although I do think some of it is
well-written but I find that a little
odd and I do think that text is way too
small when you're playing oh man oh like
it should have been
they should have kind of like so Chris
part of it
- sorry Chris Gomez part of it is the
controller joy Khan's just not being as
I know a sharp is that a good word to
use yeah and I don't know if that's on
the devs I think that's maybe literally
just like the way the joy gone like
because you were like when you're
playing on the pro controller yeah it
was
well there we go I think it's I think
this is way better if this feels
instantly better than when I was doing
it with this so at least for me I think
I think it's just the joy conference
which is I don't know like I never
really noticed it until now and I think
it's just intense
PO Jaisal saying I bought a switch today
but didn't get to dooms actually not out
till tomorrow but he says that he bought
Odyssey in splatoon to figure those
would be two good choices to start with
yeah those are two really excellent
choices to start with I would say if you
should definitely check out breath of
the wild at some point it was like the
sole reason I bought a switch and it was
worth every penny star do you love your
star do that would work that would
totally work yeah that was holy work I
think that's the cool part is like now
you get to get some of those experiences
on handheld which you wouldn't have had
before and they are very you know they
will play very well oh so I will get a
chance on Luke it's not worth it if you
see that it keeps dipping in frames
that's kind of part of what it's
happening or it could also be your
internet eventually
and we're if we are me the good way to
tell that is we look at us right like
that we look fine for the games dipping
then that's the game if we're dipping to
you then that's needed
yeah as space manatee has just mentioned
if you want a portable version of this
game obviously get on the switch but if
you don't and you have like you know
peace war xbox or pc that's probably the
way to go that's what I would say as
well but you know the portability would
be the one kind of factor here so that's
one of the things you're going for even
though John Luke is shaking his head I
think personally makes me want to play
it portable I think it's
sitting down like that so that was one
of the audio there you go Bob yeah at
least everyone got to hear it yeah we're
gonna hear that nice audio glitch these
jump pads on yes looks tough I love the
portability of the switch and I like
every game should come to the switch but
this is kind of making me realize
I don't know and I still I gotta try
this I gotta try this at some point I'm
gonna feel I feel like why did you the
control get your opinion yeah we'll get
a fresh perspective
day one playing the dooms yeah as I said
I'm sorry
acrid dread says it's it's not a casual
game that you play in your bed no I did
try it I don't know I beat you like I'm
so riled up when I played this game kind
of you know like I'm so like on it like
kind of on edge my Adrenaline's going
that like I don't really see myself just
kind of like relaxing on the bed like
killing demons right now to some
bombastic like metal music it's like
yeah like if I wasn't gonna drown us out
I would just like play them like audio
louder just so I can just hear the music
cuz I love it's so good
later Brandon again beginner sorry sure
run Rox 26 asking when our sonic forces
rule will come hopefully by the end of
the week we didn't have like an early
copy like some outlets had somehow
procured I know Matt Espinel he's on the
case so he'll be working on that and
hopefully I don't want to put words into
his mouth and maybe another week I crazy
I don't remember that death animation
maybe I'm so used to court glory killing
the remnants that uh I've never had him
kind of like yeah like his jet pack goes
crazy I mean explodes it's so satisfying
though that is still bit like I just
glory kill everything oh you know what's
great too is um that's what you get for
looking at a man say you get that data
upgrade later where you can glory kill
from even farther I like it's the best
it's just like it's like it reminds me
of Call of Duty like a knife when knife
was broken and you could just like
commando lunge knife except it's a glory
kill okay alright what am I playing here
and how do i wheel how do i wheel here
do you want to controller or I'll try to
I can't first let me get alright first
hands-on with the joy Collins we'll see
how this all right aim and shoot and
wheels that and uh what's jump jump yeah
okay well I'll figure it out we get on
the stick for melee no I'm gonna do this
oh yeah go do that too do I have to
switch this over though I think I just
got it no I didn't do I want to do that
level yeah alright sure it's good it's
good demanding no worries here we go
so anyone says any love for snipper
clips plus I have a are they doing like
a plus version and super close I played
all of some years has fun time with
snipper clips I played the whole thing
with my girlfriend it was very fun fun
time yeah it's multiplayer included yes
goblins 70-79
I don't know if anyone's on though
because we're on early right now I don't
know if anyone's playing but there is
multiplayer which is interesting
interesting I put it in
I don't know if that the switch
ecosystem is really what I want for do
multiplayer but I also didn't really
care for do multiplayer that much so all
right let's hope I get bronze what oh
okay okay the list stick was oh god wait
is the right stick even working no it's
not okay there you go there you go okay
okay I lost time there didn't I
it feels not as precise as I would want
it to be no also I've always found it
weird though personally to not have like
the control what is that if I can go
grab that little control thing for my
desk if you want oh yeah I'm doing that
thing where you were doing yeah it's
like I'm not even yeah that's probably
gonna get hold like I said pretty fast
but yeah it's definitely not as precise
as I would want it to be because and
I'll try it with the pro controller here
in a second but uh that's kind of fun
though that yeah I don't know if that's
gonna get old for me because I think I
would do that every time yeah it's very
gonna be collection for switch ah that'd
be great actually one in three would be
awesome guns
yeah kiss to start
however I don't there's no indication
that that's ever gonna happen and I know
Konami okay seem interested in doing
anything with Silent Hill so I wouldn't
hold out hope for that but okay yep
great start didn't do great oh gotta get
the muscle memory I will say Amy what
this thing was not that great no it's
not it's really not it just I don't know
if it's because because it's thumbsticks
smaller here right then the pro
controller oh it is yeah yeah part of
its the size for sure
no I think the size of those are just
very tiny but then also it's the pro
controller one more one more one where
it go I really that wasn't a true
experience
I didn't realize I didn't have all my
tools and I want you guys to experience
what I'm experiencing for the first time
I don't even have a double jump this is
just didn't feel like I did it's a
little sensitive okay I didn't change
any of the controls this is default fare
I feel like if you're gonna be doing the
joy Khan thing you might be doing what
me and John Luke are doing which is
you're just gonna keep the crosshair in
the middle and strafing the way okay you
played this game on a controller right
yeah I did
says something like it was definitely
joining for me going from mouse keyboard
to controller but I did I didn't blame
them on the switch I definitely talk
that up too it's like switching from
mouse and keyboard key word controller
is always kind of a little bit jarring
cuz I do think the poke control is
actually fun yeah yeah totally I'm
totally doing that thing
that doesn't bother you then maybe maybe
that's fine for that God not tired of
that yet no I view it as it's a
mechanic's junk that I have to do it
personal best
yeah so yeah the aiming is not not so
great it's it's a little cumbersome it
kind of slides more than you would want
it to I guess is how I feel
wait am I supposed to acquiesce oh [ __ ]
I am no backward race to the joy cons
aren't meant for anything that's kind of
the sense I've gotten yeah but if that's
the case then like isn't that a problem
because it's like the whole crux of
people talking about handheld and what
am I using right now what I would be
using at least for me because I I think
if you got two camps of people you got
maybe someone who owns the switch and
just a switch and it's never played doom
in which case yeah like I could see you
being interested in this just by some of
its issues right but then I think a lot
of people were just like we've already
played doom we're like oh I want to play
it on handheld that's really cool but if
that's what I thought and then that for
me kind of removes a lot of the appeal
of doom on the switch that's that's the
point of it right right yeah so it's not
it's not that bad but yeah you would
definitely have to almost do the thing
where we what we're doing right now
which is like I'm mainly just strafing
into my shots I'm not really aiming my
shots because if I try to aim it's like
and maybe my dexterities potentially bad
but like you know like normally you'd
want to be able to like you know Fred
like frenetically just kind of like you
know go around them and like
you know like do that and it's it's it's
fine it's just not as precise as I would
like it to be personally met Marcel
saves up to a point well if it's down to
one xbox one out here the switch version
will play like what do you think of it
on Xbox I played on PC and I had a great
time
did you like enjoy it on on Xbox by the
way Wolfenstein she was Game of the Year
it's definitely up there for me I
haven't really I'm not even gonna open
that bag yeah right
I even organized my top ten list but
it's Wolfenstein to be is definitely
somewhere on there for sure people are
recommending lowering the sensitivity
sing about outs we can try that how do I
get the plus button controller alright
so 30% will remember that for yeah we
can oh isn't there like a default revert
to default 2x let's try 20 good thing
you're not an invert crazy crazy
enriched guy he'll do I go okay jump up
that high
door losing my bonus man almost almost
almost failed
Oh God collectible Oh this takes your
life no actually I just wanted
collectible
[Applause]
I'm still doing that thing guys when I'm
like strafing into it you're interested
I did a history of Sonic a couple months
ago covers every Sonic game ever made
it's a pretty good video should go watch
it you haven't seen it almost feels like
20 might have been too - too much - yeah
still kind of like not really it's just
not I don't know doesn't feel it doesn't
feel good whatever right for whatever
reason we'll do it next level I guess am
i close
we'll find out I bet I bet it's gonna be
tremendously different though hmm no Bob
I have not tried Sonic 4 curious though
I really like Sonic mania a lot you
didn't do that like Japanese like 1
minute demo or whatever was like they're
like 1 1 minute stages
but i i love sonic mania and i did not
mean to be quite like Sonic Generations
kind of carrying this game was sort of
kind of eight generations was promising
but it sounds like it it's maybe not as
good
Oh framerate oh please please
they couldn't handle the explosions and
all the characters on the screen I think
that was pretty that's the worst it's
been though for sure
oh it's not handling this maybe that is
it that right here is a good indication
of framerate like most of the time I'd
say serviceable but you will experience
moments like this for sure
see the thing - that's a little bit
deceiving for me right now is that I'm
using the shotgun right which has a
little bit more forgiveness in terms of
the crosshair like if I was using the
Gauss Rifle with like go ahead okay
going on gotta have some it's got to
have something like a counter show that
framerate is is doing some dip in I
really want that armor hey you come oh
because you're climbing I can't
should we just I'll forego the armor I
wit got time play don't die like that
keep picking up the assault rifle and
when I don't oh all right there you are
give me the give me this give me the
real deal yeah how do I do
come on damn
not even im a skrub tear don't want
different map yes please okay let's do
Arcade Mode here and that the game plays
smoothly and handheld which is nice no
it's about the same I haven't noticed
any difference sorry say again someone
was asking if it plays smoother on
handheld oh yeah I haven't played I
haven't played it on handheld myself so
I can't help and I have not noticed any
difference
like the framerate problem still
happened okay gotcha
I have I know that there have definitely
been cases where handheld versus doc
I've had some noticeable like framerate
differences I have not noticed are we
are Kading or am I just playing we are
kidding we're just gonna pay gimme gimme
that felt good just for the perspective
that I like playing do yeah we're gonna
switch back to 2:30 or revert
so was asking if there's a demo no it's
out tomorrow I'm aware if there's no
demo for it
Skyrim wants which will be next week
havoc and we won't be streaming that
we'll see ya 17 days battlefront oh
that's right well uh that's a good time
to we got time during the screen I mean
we could just have someone play with my
loadout that loadout so oh so I couldn't
did that just now - so you do get it
just gives you the weapons you have up
to that point but I think you can change
which equip you have so you want to
switch to my chrome is yeah I do
yeah I prefer explosive YouTube yeah use
the stun bomb someone was so good
against like the big guys cuz then like
so how do I do which button is that is
that the it's or just to do the double
turn fire it's isn't isn't this is tame
though really
you can't ABS my crazy you can 80s on
the the rifle if you don't pick the oh
[ __ ] I need to know I need settings oh I
feels are already tremendously better
right okay I'll probably whoa how come
defaults 40 I don't know that's weird I
never am like adjusted to default
well I'm gonna play on default just play
default then that's weird oh maybe it
changes it depending on which how's that
feel a lot better but I've played it
this way too though right yeah Oh what's
my melee now oh sorry I was doing sorry
I was doing the flick manage just
realized oh this is okay just right off
the bat I just want to say this is a lot
better than the handheld controller so
do I want that am I gonna die Joe it's a
bait seed you're not gonna know hey give
me the Terminator give me that oh I'm
silly whatever give me the Terminator oh
come on you don't think I could've made
that no definitely not that was not the
way to make that for sure oh it's right
in plain sight
how long can you play do on hand help
what's the battery life actually I'm not
yes rip that was a rip I was trying to
get the thing but I want to say that
play my pro controller immediately felt
a lot better
hopefully it kept all my settings
yeah it's like so much right aim like
holy crap to get me easier yeah it'sit's
which is a bummer because I think that
really ruins the handheld experience
like yeah this already you know what I
mean it's like one of those things like
this is how it's supposed to be yeah
definitely
oh that bob was around that's kind of
cool
someone's asked if there's motion
controls kind of the motion controls
Tate was doing earlier is you just kind
of flick the right number and you'll
like do the melee attack extent of
motion controls no it's telling me to go
so many plays bring the demons
so the framerate dip is pretty bad I'm
confident they will patch it though
maybe I hope so but I don't know I don't
know enough about Oh God the way this
game works in the architecture to say if
it is passable
maybe maybe to some degree but I get
pretty rough or I like that - now you
just any videos things like motion blur
yes we could turn it off do you wanna
turn it off all right yeah so it
defaults to a really high motion blur
yeah and so yeah we could turn the
motion blur off let's do that
anything else yes motion boy is now off
do that jump pad
kondeh totally forgot where to go it's
been a while it was like oh I know you
could go this way somehow but oh you
need to is that the key card all right
we got yellow key card and not see any
like yellow entrances though
what really doesn't mantle that should
and whatever do you know oh hello
yeah well there you go
what do I have for ammo so instead is
how this is compared to the counselor PC
version of the game water
we find that obviously like the frame
rates not as good visually it's not as
great probably the biggest issue for my
chainsaw this whole time oh sorry sorry
yeah that's why would be the the biggest
issues for me that really kind of maker
Burk the game is like really drastic and
framerate dips that happened and then
the joy con controller is feeling really
really bad pro controller immediately
feels a lot like I can actually like do
what I want to do bring your pro
controller with you and stand up the
switch does that count
why not it's red card red cards good yes
what I guess not how to remove numbers
on display I assume you're talking about
the we're playing arts our game right
now yeah so those numbers like pop up to
show you your score if you just play
regular campaign
none of that stuff pops up let's get a
million get bronze
I think that's worth doing whatever lot
of heated debate about just I loved the
switch as a console I think it's
fantastic I think it's just you know
it's a it is like a lot of Nintendo
system this the hardware very much fit
certain games example of you know dudes
probably not the best place for
something like this which you know like
Zelda and Mario and countless other
games have been like fantastic on the
switch and it's my preferred platform to
play I think it is a fantastic piece of
hardware where we could go down here but
might not be worth it right now yeah I
just don't remember everything I
remember this map was like the one that
had like a crap ton of Goonies that's
the thing about Arcade Mode is it kind
of that I just want to kill stuff hmm so
you kind of have to like remember what
to do like I should be jumping to get
that thing that's for sure can you I
only have yellow key card right now okay
and I got to get to wherever that thing
is so I guess I got to jump down is it
there there's a secret level on this one
- did you know that like if you
activated this thing
[Applause]
how's the chat doing okay a lot of a lot
of debating about consoles can turn to a
little bit of a comfortable yeah console
wars I love them can't stand console
coming from the guy that loves his PC
just give me a hard time
hey console war peace no that's not
gonna work
back the other way [ __ ] well you
have to activate all three of them I
know but I haven't found the third not
the key card but like you got stopped a
demonic thing would do dads who
remembers this level I don't I went down
there I D I killed that wait can you go
through that door go go forward yeah I
tried going through this order it's not
down there because we definitely did
that trying to remember it's not just
played this the other day - way to go
John Luke and I don't think it's up
yellow key card there it is just had to
keep exploring oh there's a collectible
in here - somewhere up in the vents
oh damn it I still got him oh please
you've got him nope nevermind it's done
are you not glory killable yet damn it
you think you're gonna play any star
mamas which probably not it was probably
a higher likelihood of me playing this
game once we play much Skyrim at all oh
hey a little I never got into it
personally doesn't seem like it's your
kind of game it's not I'm all about that
that mood in that action I never liked
scare him as much as I wanted to I like
absolutely loved oblivion Morland to
death and then I played along scared but
I didn't accomplish as much as I feel
like I was I want to like it's just the
drive wasn't there and I'm not sure if
it's the case that games design isn't as
intuitive as or what I wanted compared
to those other games where maybe if I
just felt burned out on that formula
kind of hard for me to tell and I felt
the same way about fallout 4
I think maybe I'm formula
oh that's garbage i frickin stunned him
oh yeah there you go
someone says need to blue being on the
switch I mean that would actually like
you can put a believing on the switch
and it probably run fine
that'd be actually kind of cool I play
every play believing on the switch
because I have a weird feel like we
should be getting a key card no like
crazy
I gotta keep going there's a booth
keycard figures
we get limited ammo though so you get it
back politically oh damn I shouldn't got
the armor you don't get ammo from you
don't get a you do in certain levels see
right there's the fuel yeah yeah yeah so
don't work it would have worked out fine
I'll do it too something in here ah no
glory kills it worth so much more what I
know no points oh yes
and it builds up your modifier more much
the chainsaw oh we gotta say that for
big guys alright no I keep killing them
nope it again
yeah proko controllers definitely the
way to go get them Jana yeah feel good
is that it ah I just wanted more give me
more monsters to a lot of goodies
they're preparing me for the big fight
dude I'm not close to the score man I'm
like halfway the bronze this is oh this
room oh this room's crazy
Nick I need your hot metal action
whoa
no I lost my eight modifier why not
worth it right now that didn't even kill
him that's fine yeah it's been pretty
fun though yeah I definitely want to
replay doom now I know it's another
interesting game that's coming out like
next week yeah interesting to see how
that's gonna play out did you play Ally
away with noir because I didn't I played
it once
actually the hoping in black and white
mode oh yeah now that was really fun
little way to experience that game been
like I went back okay like try to level
in color and it's this bit with like her
car and there's like blood in the car I
was like oh my god there's so much more
blood than I thought it was yeah I'm
actually kind of want to replay that
only play it once and my girlfriend's
never played it and she likes you know
detective detective II story based game
so she would actually probably be really
into it oh if that's not what I want but
then the question is do I want to play
on switch do I want to play it I don't
know when it's coming out but I know
they're also doing 4k versions for like
the pro and X so like you all want to
get those versions instead or also there
apparently is a VR version of it and I
know nothing about this VR version but
Ben was telling me that apparently it is
like the entire game in VR which sounds
I mean I have a hard time believing that
because like I don't know when you take
a game that was never designed so as we
are from the ground up and say like the
whole game is on VR I can't imagine
that's gonna be bad
but I've also never seen anything about
it we failed yeah yeah I mean like I
didn't do it from a score perspective I
think there might be a little bit more
to this level no I think that's it
pretty sure that was that's a big room
right yeah all right well there okay so
first impressions for me sans actually
playing handheld which I can kind of
imagine in my head
sorry that's a little sweaty pro
controller definitely plays the way you
would think if you played on controller
before or haven't but I would definitely
tell you if you have a pro controller to
do that instead of using the joy kansai
I mean like doing this to get a glory
kills kind of novel but like the aiming
is just not as precise on the George
Collins for sure you want to try out we
won't find a match that's fine give it a
go but we'll give it like a quick yeah
seconds but if we don't find one that's
fine
this scheme might have BOTS I don't know
we could try and see if it has BOTS sure
just and then we'll call it as well yeah
thank you guys all for tuning in hanging
out with me and John Luke playing some
doom on switch hopefully you guys are
enjoying yourself and customize your
dude but I guess again do a long way
curious if you guys are picking up doom
wear if you guys just gonna I imagine
there's no one no there's not anybody
playing maybe we can hit up Peter
hey Peter let's 1v1 Samus silly man
asking how do you all there's BOTS
awesome sweet how do you think Skyrim
will fit into the switch ecosystem hey
which map do you want to play I think
we'll be fine it just depends on how it
ends up playing see but it's kind of
cool to have Skyrim on the go though
that's for sure
bought skills normal yeah the game won't
maintain solid 30 the entire time as
I'll take certain areas will make it dip
I know 15-20 minutes ago as another user
I think cowboy Tropicana mentioned our
FES was like had to be single digits
that one time when it just like when
we're outside that one time it really it
really just was not so hot the FPS in
that area is L tick was like a constant
single FPS for like a little bit until I
got like either killed all the monsters
or got to the next area that like one
area was real sketchy and as gianluca's
mentioned from playing you know several
hours now there it just depends on where
it is the framerate for the most part is
like okay but then there are times where
it gets like really hichy and just not
so hot so it kind of implies I maybe
need at least another human person is
there anything else you guys want us to
check out or we pretty good I mean yeah
cuz multiplayer is clearly not gonna
work as most people don't have it
obviously so that's a bummer that you
can't just play play bots period right
like unless I'm missing something but
that's kind of what it seems to be
implying bummer bummer so we checked out
our cave mode and Sega player that's the
only other to rule yep alright cool well
thanks John Luke for kind of sharing
your opinions on doom switch yeah I mean
if you saw this and it seems like some
people in the chat still feel like it is
an acceptable enough for them that
they'll never want to buy it which any
worse go play enjoy each their own
absolutely yeah
certainly not gonna take that away from
anyone yeah but if you want my opinion I
think if you want if you've already
played doom on on other platforms I
don't think there's too much reason to
necessarily want to play this unless you
really really wanna play love doom and
want to go hand hill
you really want to go Han how old in
you're willing to put up with the joy
Khan's lesson seller aiming otherwise if
you've never played in before then this
might be a way to play it that could be
good then ask what's practice mode
yeah also uh when playing a hand Holi
solo with a bot here we go okay can't
maybe do this do you need to leave this
oh no you know okay here's another quick
question for you from chat was it blurry
in handheld - yes okay yes - the like I
had a head my glasses off but I have
your nearsighted I'm nearsighted yeah I
normally I was like well I can still see
you close I put them on still blurry
okay so shears not actually ending guys
it turns out we can play BOTS so we'll
play multiplayer a little more thanks
Ben it was Ben Gingka thanks Ben
appreciate it
ooh UAC field drop man they got all the
swag maybe maybe we haven't I just
didn't add any customizing about let's
see I forgot there were like
multiplayers specific weapons oh it's
only in the multiplayer that's why he
didn't remember it
ooh it's really blurry this looks like
blurrier I feel or like uh yeah I know
what you're talking about though looking
just in general yeah are they at I
wonder if it's because they feel like
they need it needs to run a faster frame
rate for multiplayer yeah
yeah suck at unwilling you know if
you're I would still swim my eyes I
think this is like Oh glory kill him
halo to or something yes you totally can
bang yeah I played enough multiplayer to
be like yep that's that's my [ __ ] yeah
well because the only reason multiplayer
was like uh fun for me when they came
out in new modes was because you think
there was like a new demon so you just
always wanted to be the new demon yeah
but some of them were crazy demon yeah
yeah that incoming I think is no that's
just haste I don't know if you I want to
see there should be somewhere that you
possessed was he a demon must be his
name I think I see that incoming that
the state and sign or the that's that's
the demon demon ruin spawned right yes I
think you got a right stick yeah okay so
what are you revenant no revenants
really good so not only do you get the
jet pack when you get rocket launchers
and the rocket launchers is yep exactly
what yep you know the Summoner so the
balancing part of this is that you have
do you have a time limit and you do have
health obviously so it's not like a
velociraptor yeah uh audio audio cut out
audio this has happened to me before
what how about that guys it's definitely
yeah it is okay yeah a little buggy with
the audio revenant just breaks
everything so the only way I've known to
fix this is you close and open exactly I
don't think we need to show a full bomb
that's fine you should at least kill
them with the revenant
there we go and what more come on six
seconds oh yeah just light them up get
them here I'll just pretend I'm the the
redneck Oh BFG Oh get Rex for that dude
with it I don't know what that PFT sound
makes oh that was more like a Murloc
yeah okay oh we got the super armor but
you got the P of T it doesn't matter
I don't remember the P of G being in
multiplayer they must have added it and
one of the updates yeah I don't I don't
remember it being in there actually
didn't play any of the multiplayer
that's fair when the game came out I
only played the beta I played the beta
and I was like I don't care about this
multiplayer so I just didn't touch it
why can't I think once you write you got
one more shot at BFG then we'll probably
call it okay I guess yeah there you go
all right cool play the audio so it is
what it is so be aware of that if you do
have the audio glitchyness at all just
open and close do and yeah so do you
want to switch coming out tomorrow if
you want to play in handheld I guess
this is gonna be the only way but as we
mentioned probably better to play with a
controller and or if you've played on
previous platforms unless you just want
to support Bethesda Nintendo you're
probably better off playing those
platforms but again that's our opinion
take that with a grain of salt but until
next time thank you guys thank you John
Luke we'll be back tomorrow at 11 a.m.
I haven't actually decided the game yet
but I will figure that out and see
something guys tomorrow
but until then thank you John Luke and
thank you everybody for tuning in thanks
guys later